italienne et je peux dire que les
Français sont très beaux ils ont
tendance à être plus marrant je suis
américain les Français sont à peu
prétentieuses personnellement je préfère
une bonne poupée Barbie américaine et
les filles sont sympas ici quand même
puis de toute façon on n'a pas le choix
donc elle se la joue un peu ouais il y
en a certaines qui sont pas mal mais
elle va percer mais elle va pas les
Suédoises
les Français sont mal foutus non elles
sont pas grosses
elles sont pas grosses
et je trouve que en général les Français
sont trop petits au Danemark on est plus
mixte des groupes mixtes alors qu'ici
bonne chance pour entamer la
conversation avec un Français hein où
ils sont vraiment coincés ou alors ils
sont trop dragués en français quand ils
viennent draguer une fille il a drague
pendant un moment après il oublie tout
de suite c'est ils sont pas vraiment
sérieux
elles allument non c'est pas vrai on a
quand même pas cette réputation là non